[Music]
what can I help you with Lord of
Darkness I'm looking for a date the date
is Friday July 13th no no I want to meet
someone understood you want to eat dim
sum don't you get it I want to go on a
date I'm lonely I understand you want
Bologna
don't many eyes though few eyes not into
Pentacles dad you're stressed out from
working too hard you need a vacation
from running everyone else's vacation
and I know just how to fix it are we
going on there's so much to do
you could go scuba diving try some
exotic food
[Music]
or just enjoy the view thank you maybe
you'll find your own fireworks on the
cruise it's not The Love Boat Frank you
must be the one and only Dracula
hey do BD Shula a coupie Dean there's
something about an accent that makes a
man sound so intelligent
you were right great-grandfather van
Helsing monsters are disgusting
they have no idea what's about to happen
today
all going according to plan
[Music]
there is something about that woman I
don't trust the food here is to die for
must have been garlic in the guacamole
that's deadly for you
hey was that you know Blondie's gonna
puke
[Music]